[Musik]
die schönsten ist
es ist so
[Musik]
ja
hey leute ich begrüße euch heute zu
einem ganz besonderen herzens video denn
das ist der beginn meiner diesjährigen
ramadan reihe
hier könnte es auch schon wen haben wir
den flitterwochen anfertigen lassen
extra für die ramadan reihe und wir
machen heute ein kleines lager video
haben sie hinter der kamera und ich vor
der kamera aber ihr solltet auch nicht
leer ausgehen denn es gibt auch ein
rezept wir machen heute leckere der
belchen und ich sage euch gleich dass
sie die benefits davon sind was für
vorteile dadurch habe und ein bisschen
möchte ich euch auch über den ramadan es
zählt weil ich weiß ich hab's nicht nur
muslimische zuschauer sondern auch ganz
viele nichtmuslimische zuschauer und ich
finde es auch mal toll dass die
nichtmuslimischen zuschauer sich auch
immer richtig toll beteiligen und die
rezepte nachmachen und auch viel zum
hintergrund der rezepte fragen sind so
kann ich euch orientalische küche auch
näher bringen ich zeige euch jetzt alle
erstmal die zutaten für unsere dafür
welchen und wenn wir zweiter
wir benötigen kokos außerdem kurkuma und
zimt hier habe ich gemeine nüsse ich
habe jetzt hier haselnüsse genommen
außerdem daten und einfach haferflocken
und best man schüsse so ich beginne
jetzt einfach indem ich die daten
entkernt müsst jetzt ganz einfach nur
den kern im inneren rausholen und ich
habe das die letzten jahre immer gerne
als resteverwertung gemacht denn ramadan
sind darin ganz traditionell mann bricht
sein fasten mit einer sattel und datteln
sind auch ein toller nährstoff lieferant
die haben so viele positive
eigenschaften man sollte eigentlich das
ganze jahr über das essen aber an
ramadan darf man ihm erst recht nicht
darauf verzichten ich habe jetzt hier
ganz frischen ist die hier die zeige ich
euch gerne die biete ich auch bei mir im
shop allein hilft nebenbei erwähnt werde
ich dass ich den job habe kann ich euch
übrigens auch orientalische lebensmittel
während ramadan anbieten
letztes jahr zum beispiel habe ich auch
ganz viele gefragt wo man dieses und
jenes her bekommt also orangenblüten
wasser und und und und deswegen fand ich
ganz toll dass wir es dieses jahr
pünktlich zu ramadan geschafft haben
diese produkte bei uns im shop
anzubieten
aber genug dazu ich möchte euch in
diesem video auch so ein paar tipps
geben so wie ich den ramadan überstehen
dann sind wir mal ehrlich also von
morgen bzw
3 bis dieses jahr 90 soll das plötzlich
so genau also von drei uhr morgens 21
und nichts essen ist schon hart es ist
auch nicht so einfach an übersteht das
irgendwie und wenn man dann die
passenden tipps und tricks hat umso
besser und jetzt gebe ich euch meinen
allerersten tipps und zwar solltet ihr
vieh natürlich jeder weiß ganz viel
wasser konsumieren ganz viel man sagt er
im alltag ist es pro kilogramm
körpergewicht 30 milliliter wasser ihr
solltet an ramadan etwas mehr trinken
denn ihr braucht er natürlich kraft für
den tag sie vermeiden solltet ist
koffein ich persönlich mag auch gerne
kaffee und ich trinke also ich trägt am
tag dreimal latte macchiato ok macchiato
und ich mag auch gerne eine cola zu
einem ist dann bin ich ganz ehrlich aber
ihr solltet an ramadan wirklich drauf
verzichten denn auch wenn ihr sagt ich
kann kaffee trinken und ich kann auch
danach problemlos schlafen
das entzieht euch nicht nur wasser okay
das sagt man kaffee entzieht wasser aber
es macht euch auch müde für den tag und
ihr habt keine konzentration deshalb
verzichtet möglichst auf koffein und
auch süße getränke auf softdrinks genau
so genau und er haben sie trinkt auch
sehr gerne cola fanta und so weiter ist
genau also wenn der hanseller schafft
dann schafft ihr das auch tipp nummer
zwei ihr solltet zum start also zum
fastenbrechen eine mischung aus
kohlenhydraten und eiweiß ist aber noch
viel viel wichtiger ist dass die ein
drittel ihres magens mit dem essen füllt
ein drittel mit wasser und der letzte
drittel der sollte leer bleiben ihr sagt
was ich es nicht und dann soll ein
drittel meines mannes leer brems
vertraut mir ihr fühlt euch fit und
vital und wenn ihr nicht bis hier oben
vor seit fühlt ihr euch einfach viel
viel viel besser
genau man bekommt ihr diesen toten punkt
eigentlich nur weil man sich dann voll
ist meine daten sind entkernt und ich
habe vier extra in eine ausreichend
große schüssel gegeben um die jetzt
probieren zu können müssen wir sie erst
mal in kochendem wasser einweichen
sie habe ich mein kochendes wasser
einfach drüber geben und drei minuten
lang stehen jetzt habe ich das wasser
weggeschüttet alles abtropfen lassen und
gibt es hier in meinen blender wir
brauchen dich jetzt dattel pürees kann
auch ruhig ein bisschen fester sein
aber hauptsache wir können es später zu
einem teig form das ist die fertige
datei passte und wenn ihr jetzt sagt ich
möchte mir die ganzen schritte sparen da
habe ich auch noch lösen für euch wollte
nur noch mal erwähnt haben weil ich weiß
die frage wird kommt ihr könnt natürlich
auch fertige das passte verwenden die
habe ich auch im shop ich weiß letztes
jahr da habe ich mal gemacht ganz
bekannt für zuckerfest opferfest dann
machen die mütter dass er immer
kiloweise dass ich dazu passte dass man
die verwenden kann und die gibt es eben
leider auch die überall oder hansa
schwierig auf jeden fall jetzt bei uns
im shop das nur noch nebenbei ansonsten
geht es natürlich auch auf diesem wege
das ist ja auch immer super easy und
jetzt gehen wir ganz einfach die
restlichen zutaten hinein und werden das
nochmal miteinander vermischten
ich habe die dattel masse jetzt in meine
schüssel gefüllt und mit den händen
geknetet wenn ihr möchtet das knackige
knusprige dafür welchen habt also so zum
beißen in die liste meine ich dann müsst
ihr das nicht kurieren man ganz einfach
mit den händen verkneten jetzt wollen
wir das ganz einfach zu kugeln das geht
hier mit den händen
denn die masse ist jetzt richtig schön
feucht so und dann einfach in
kokosraspeln wälzen wobei dieser schritt
auch optional ist und fertig und weiter
geht es mit tipp nummer rote reihe
diesen lege ich wirklich jedem ans herz
macht die nacht nicht durch macht
einfach nicht selbst ich ja ich habe
auch fehler gemacht ich habe auch ab und
zu mal wirklich vom stahl bis zum sowohl
durchgemacht und am nächsten tag war ich
so ich war es gut ich konnte einfach
nicht mehr
ich konnte meine aufgabe nicht
bewältigen ich war unkonzentriert
studenten jetzt ja von 120 euro ja da
mache ich durch und dann schlaf ich auch
der größte fehler den wir machen kann
ist in ruhe
nehmt euch die zahl macht ihr pünktlich
zum sowohl auf ist frühstücken de
kleinigkeit und am besten sind natürlich
auch diese dafür welchen geeignet halten
euch wirklich auch lange satt und das
ist auch wieder mal so ein kleiner tipp
am rande wenn ihr mal verschläft oder so
keine zeit habt euch ein brust zu
beweisen sagt ein paar dafür welchen
essen und fertig das habe ich nämlich
letztes jahr ein paar mal so gemacht und
genau das ist mein dritter tipp und den
ich wirklich sehr sehr sehr sehr ans
herz
tipp nummer vier damit ihr auch während
des monats wirklich fit und vital bleibt
treibt gerne ein bisschen sport der
diese zehn minuten 15 minuten workout es
gibt sogar sieben minuten workouts oder
so gibt es alles ihr könnt ihr einfach
auf youtube gucken aber gerne 12
das ist ganz wichtig leute kurz vor ich
da nicht tagsüber chur zwölfter denn
dann könnte er nachdem ihr geschwitzt
habt könnt ihr eure dattel essen sind
ihr trinken und essen oder die zweite
option wäre ihr wartet bis zum iftar
sache das will suppe treibt sport ist
dann richtig dass wir die zweite option
das sind die fertigen doppel welchen
richtig schönen nährstoffreich und
sättigen dieses und ganz ganz viele
weitere rezepte erwarten euch das ist ja
jetzt wirklich nur so dieses einstiegs
rezept das ist sowohl füße holt also zum
frühstück sag ich mal als auch nach dem
fasten recht snacks super geeignet was
ich jetzt im abschluss noch sagen möchte
das finde ich nämlich ganz ganz wichtig
dass es jedem selbst überlassen ist wie
er den ramadan zelebriert so ob man
jetzt vom fernseher sitzt und die zeit
totschlägt und fußball guckt oder so
oder viel verspielt genau oder ob man es
wirklich für sich spirituell aufnimmt
und richtig für sich zelebriert das ist
jedem selbst überlassen und das
privatangelegenheit
genau konnte so nicht besser sagen kann
ich so unterschreiben einen bug und koch
kanal und ich finde es auch toll dass
ich euch die orientalischen rezepte
gerade zu meiner ramadan reihe richtig
schön näher bringen kann
viele von euch kennen die schon aber es
gibt auch viele die sie nicht kennen und
ich habe auch ganz ganz viele nicht
muslimische zuschauer die sich dann
total freuen wenn dann irgendwas
orientalisches kommt und wirklich die
schritt-für-schritt-anleitung und man
muss ja auch sagen letzte sie hat mir
ganz viele rezepte dabei dies im
deutschsprachigen raum noch gar nicht
gibt also finde ich auch total besonders
und ich werde euch die videos der
letzten reihe mal in der infobox
anhängen die playlist könnt ihr euch
gerne mal durchklicken und jetzt wünsche
ich einen gesegneten ramadan monat und
ich freue mich auf ihn in meinen
nächsten videos erleben
[Musik]
sonst lesen
nach dem besten steht
unser leben
jetzt sind
[Musik]